moi j'ai fait ce métier pour monter sur
scène tout ce que je fais à côté c'est
pour nourrir la scène pour nourrir la
relation avec le public donc de plus
pouvoir le faire effectivement c'est on
al impression un peu d'avoir de ne plus
avoir d'arrivées d'oxygène et cela fait
huit mois que ça dure
pour gabriel pour jouer à bout musicien
et professeur de musique indépendants
dans le loir et cher
ce deuxième confinement est vécue comme
une double peine privé de seine depuis
le mois de mars il a aussi dû fermer son
école qui accueille une trentaine
d'élèves
le terme non essentiels il est un peu
dure pour pour certains parce que ben
oui pour nous notre métier est essentiel
pour nous fatalement mais je pense que
là que la culture la gastronomie la
musique l'art c'est essentiel à de
nombreux points guitariste et batteur
gabriel et son orchestre assure une
cinquantaine de dates par an s'il a
souvent pensé à arrêter
gabriel résiste parce qu'il a la musique
dans la peau financièrement il tient bon
grâce à l'aide aux indépendants de 1500
euros au total en région centre ce sont
10 millions d'euros qui ont été versés
par l'état à la culture
[Musique]
par rapport aux besoins qui ont été
exprimés on a réussi effectivement à
travers les dispositifs du gouvernement
ou du ministère de la culture à faire en
sorte que en région pour le moment il
n'y a pas de décalage vraiment qui s'est
opéré entre les demandes et les moyens
qu'on a pu affecter je suis fan de la
série
l'iliade beginning la région centre val
de loire compte 5700 intermittents ils
ont jusqu'au 31 août 2021 pour réaliser
leur heure mais encore faut-il réussir à
les faire avec l'intermittence on tient
le coup pour l'instant parce que il ya
une année blanche
mais il n'ya reconfirmant donc qui dira
confinement là c'est pendant un mois à
mois et demi est ce qu'il ya une
troisième vague
combien de temps ça va durer et les
spectacles ont été annulés certains
reporté mais pas à 100%
donc c'est à dire que de nombreux
artistes vont avoir des cachets en moins
si derrière on n'est ce pas encore une
petite flexibilité évidemment il ya un
nombre d'artistes et paquets technicien
créateurs qui vont qui vont péricliter
une éclaircie quand même et c'était la
particularité de ce second confinement
les artistes ont eu la possibilité de
répéter comme ici à l'espace quinière de
blois et donc de générer quelques
cachets alors c'est une histoire d'amour
qui se déroule entre un homme et une
femme enfin moore
soir d'amour quoi mais en fait cette
histoire d'amour elle n'aurait pas dû
avoir lieu
parce qu'en fait elle va être le
déclencheur d'une guerre impitoyable qui
va durer dix ans caroline glissé on a
ainsi pu pendant ce mois de novembre
travailler avec le directeur artistique
de la ben compagnie sur la réécriture de
l'iliade pour le jeune public est
essentiel de pouvoir se voir pour
travailler et répéter c'est la
répétition s'est fait refaire refaire
s'échanger des intentions attisera par
webcam
enfin voilà c'est pas la même chose et
des coupures remplissage à mi-terrain
campagne donc je vous dis pas le
capharnaüm en termes de réseau la ben
compagnie compte une quinzaine de
comédiens intermittents avec ses
périodes de crises successives et les
difficultés financières des
collectivités
la compagnie de théâtre associative a dû
repenser son modèle de création on sait
diva farc créées ce que j'appelle ma des
petites formes ces deux trois quatre
comédiens maxi de bien penser à la
scénographie donc pour les scénographes
par exemple ça est quelque chose d'assez
délicat de ne pas avoir des guides et
des corps très costaud pour pouvoir
tourner et donc là on est là dessus on
va et télé moi je dis les petites
compagnies les créateurs il va falloir
créer des nouvelles formes doit se jouer
en janvier
on pense à aller dans les classes
essayer de faire des modules
parce qu'on ne sait pas du tout si on
pourra jouer en salle si on pourra faire
venir les écoles donc on anticipe là on
réfléchit donc ça nous oblige quelque
part à inventer d'autres formes mais
rien ne vaut quand même mes
représentations avec un public à
l'illiade the beginning vous connaissez
vous reconnaissez pas connaissez pas
vous me faites marcher ou pas par pour
beaucoup très bien regarde